samedi de mobilisation en france contre
passani tard il sera étendu aux lieux de
loisirs et de culture dès le 21 juillet
début août cette mesure concernera les
lieux de la vie quotidienne comme les
bars les cafés les restaurants ou encore
les centres commerciaux mesure loin de
faire l'unanimité manifestation dont
dans toute la france entre 20000 et
quarante mille personnes sont attendues
à paris mobilisation organisée par tj
des jaunes puis mobilisation ce rappel
de plusieurs personnalités politiques
notre reporter lucas dg et dans le
cortège place du palais royal on nous
revend à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
bonjour le cas alors est-ce qu'il garde
du monde aujourd'hui
oui il ya beaucoup de monde et il ya eu
même une véritable cohue lorsque florian
philippot est arrivé à la place du
palais royal
juste avant le départ de cette
manifestation ces manifestants ils sont
tous très remontés évidemment contre les
annonces des manuels macron prononcer le
2 juillet sur l'extension du pass
sanitaire une extension car qui juge
illégale
on entendait parfois les mots de
dictatorial ici eh bien ils sont très
remontés notamment nicolas dupont aignan
qui a rejoint cette manifestation je
vous propose d'écouter ce qu'il disait
tout à l'heure c'est le début d'un
engrenage vers une dictature c'est un
coup d'état sanitaires
c'est l'instrumentalisation de la peur
de la maladie pour asseoir un pouvoir de
plus en plus illégitime
voilà et je pèse mes mots et je les
assume à 100 % ces manifestants ils
craignent une extension de ce pass à
d'autres aspects de la vie que la
vaccination ils craignent l'instauration
d'une sorte de crédit social à la
chinoise il y avait aussi dans ce
cortège notamment l'ancien député macro
nist martin von heures je vous propose
d'écouter ce qu'elle nous a dit au nom
de quoi
au nom de quoi meurtrir à ce point 67
millions de français la cabine est
devenu un chiffon rouge très simplement
pour mettre en place une nouvelle
société une société que les français ne
veulent pas une société que nous
refusons et nous sommes tout cela
ensemble pour crier notre soif de
liberté
or ce camp politique et bien d'autres
forces et bien se sont opposés à ce
passe sanitaire il ya eu notamment
l'ancien tête de liste et l'air aux
élections européennes françois xavier à
bellamy qui a publié une tribune contre
l'instauration de ce pass sanitaires se
passe ta guitare est aussi critiquée par
jean luc mélenchon à gauche et le député
elle est fille françois ruffin a appelé
à rejoindre des manifestations il ya eu
plusieurs appels à manifester partout en
france et aussi à paris merci à lucas
pour toutes ces précisions se retrouvent
lors de notre prochaine édition